there is a spot in Florida that's very
popular with Summer tourists that has
now become America's deadliest Beach
this year yikes we are talking about
Panama City Beach where eight people
have drowned after rip currents pulled
them away from Shore now there are
warnings posted there but some
beachgoers just ignore them Mark
Strassman is in Panama City Beach where
the local sheriff says he is beyond
frustrated Mark good morning I get it
hey Gail good morning to you beyond
frustrated because these deaths were
preventable the warning system here he
mentioned is really simple to understand
a single red flag means that water is
trouble a double red flag here means
that water is closed but plenty of
people wait in any way and they put
their lives on the line and rescue his
lives on the line
[Music]
Daryl Paul's the safety director of a
Nine Mile Stretch of sand suddenly
Infamous as America's most dangerous
Beach
most number of people you've rescued one
day I stopped counting around like 15 15
in one day yeah I mean like on one
rescue you can get five or six the
reason rip currents like the ones in
this aerial photo powerful and fast
moving up to eight feet per second
impossible to swim against on Shore Paul
can spot them easily most of us can't
where's the rip the Rip's gonna be over
here last month an unusual stationary
front generated winds and waves that
created countless rips one 10-day
stretch here was a specially deadly
Paul's team performed 73 rescues they
saved 143 people but six others drowned
all men all out of state vacationers and
all of them died trying to rescue
someone else
he was born with a hero's heart the way
he came into the world is the way he
left it yes it sure was
Aaron alford's Brother Richie was the
first of the six to drown the 52 year
old retired firefighter tried rescuing
two men that was one fear that he just
had he couldn't stand the thought of him
drowning
and when you heard that he had in fact
drowned that was rough and the only
Silver Line in the S2 people did come
out of life
but it wasn't him in this video deputies
and helicopters urged a swimmer on a
board to leave the water Witnesses said
he repeatedly refused when he finally
complied he ran trying to avoid deputies
chasing him down on the beach
Bay County Sheriff Tommy Ford posted I
am beyond frustrated personal
responsibility is the only way to ensure
that no one else dies too often here's
the irony the drowning victim is The
would-be Rescuer you see somebody in
trouble Temptation for a lot of folks is
getting ready yeah save them that's a
bad move need called 911 right away get
a lifeguard coming but when the double
red flag flies the real Lifesaver is
compliance no matter how big you are no
matter how great a swimmer you are
you're gone
if you do find yourself trapped by a rip
current number one rule Don't Panic try
to signal for help and then try to swim
sideways parallel with the current until
it releases you but the worst thing you
can do is try to try to swim against it
to try to fight it you're not going to
win that battle although Tony you got to
say maybe the worst thing you can do is
to ignore that double red flag to begin
with yes oh boy Mark uh quite a report
that's a great tip there at the end
thank you very much for that I was
telling you guys during the piece that
I've definitely defied the red flag
before thinking I'm from Florida I'm a
good swimmer I know what I'm doing yeah
uh but clearly doesn't that make you
think differently though yes I mean it
definitely does makes you think
differently because everybody thinks I
am a good swimmer I can do it and Mark's
advice we hear this all the time swim
parallel with it I think that's hard to
remember when you're in the situation
what gets me is you're not just putting
yourself in danger if you get into
trouble what you realize for Mark's
report is you The Rescuers can also die
yeah absolutely and you notice he said
all the victims were men yes well I
don't think that's a coincidence hello
man yeah we're trying to save other
people oh yeah yeah but it's preventable
it's preventable in many cases